the only thing they can be short of
about the future is it'll be absolutely
fantastic the arthur c-- clark center
for human imagination into the
impossible podcast inside of kovat
quarantine day I think this is day 26 or
something like that for the state of
California where Michael is now you're
up in Santa Barbara Michael yep yeah so
yeah we've been under lockdown but we're
trying to do some some fun things for
the audience out there keep everybody
entertained while this lasts hopefully
not too much longer I think this will be
renamed you know the year of the zoom or
something they'll have to change the way
we orchestrate these years but uh you
know the law you've written so many
books actually I think you know with I
can't see your hands but I assume you're
writing another book as we're speaking
because I think this is what you're 60
how many books have you written
yeah sixteen books if you can't do your
essay collections and and edited volumes
and so on
I think it's third twelve or thirteen
just solo regular trade books like this
yeah well I've always wanted to be a
writer I like writing I got to the point
where if I don't do it I feel anxious in
the same way where you know I'm a long
time lifelong cyclist yeah
competitive cyclist if I don't ride
every day or workout every day pretty
much six seven days a week I start to
feel anxious and it feels like that for
me I always like to have riding projects
something such that when I'm consuming
content myself which I like to do like
like like most of us now particularly in
isolation you know just grinding through
articles and and books and so on and the
reason I started my own podcast was
because I was reading these books anyway
and but when I it's nice to when I'm
reading something to put it somewhere
like what why do I care about this well
this is going to be part of chapter 7 in
this project I'm working on about moral
progress or whatever you know I for me I
feel better when I can fit it in
somewhere like that the reason I'm
investing all this time in reading all
these articles is are there's gonna be
part of a chapter and it makes me feel
like I'm he's
my time more efficiently yeah actually
got that idea from you a long time ago
listening to your podcast you mentioned
this is your philosophy that you know
the one way to stay engaged with other
people's ideas to read their books and
you make the point that you know books
for there's a law of physics that not
too many people know about but new books
have to come out on Tuesdays and you
brought that to my attention and of
course yeah all of our books come in on
Tuesdays for some reason and every
Tuesday you run the science salon
podcast and you usually nine times out
of ten have a new author a book or some
some work of note that has just been
released and so I took it upon myself to
kind of follow your advice and reached
out to a lot of people that have been
guest on your podcast and many of them
I've graciously agreed to be on so in
the future we're gonna have folks like
Peter Diamandis and Neil Shubin and and
folks that you know and and have had on
your show so it's a great treat to have
you I was on your show last year science
salon that was a great treat for me we
talked for over an hour and a half I
think it was and really exposed you me
to you to the way that you have a unique
style of really as an intellectual I
think of you as a public intellectual
you're reputed to be a member of some
certain three-letter acronym that I'm
not gonna mention but what I love about
you is that you can do it all you're
kind of very peripatetic you you do
everything from hard science where you
and I have cars but a lot down to the
political down to you know social
matters and so forth psychology which I
have no expertise and other than
armchair psychotherapy that is now being
conducted over zoom like most things but
you know one one question just before we
get into the meat of the book we're
gonna talk a lot about Michaels fabulous
new book giving the devil his due and I
want to get all the juicy details I read
more than half of the book in one
sitting it was just really gripping and
I'm a subscriber to skeptic magazine for
a long time but before I do that I just
wanted to circle back to this podcast
we're eating I've heard it said that
sometimes though a reading addiction it
can be addictive
sometimes it can be used as a way to
forestall one's own creativity as a
writer in other words oh I'll I'll start
writing my sequel to losing them
prai's wants I'm done interviewing
Michael and Peter and Neil and maybe
seven more articles online today Yeah
right oh I do that all the time it's a
great procrastination look you know I
gotta just read one more article I'm
sure this is important yeah exactly and
so the the you know knowledge base from
which to reference in the book just
keeps growing unavoidably well I'm you
know the current age we live in with the
Internet it's so accessible at any given
time I'll have like a dozen windows open
you know just like in the first hour of
the mornings like I got to read this I
got to read this I'm going to come back
to this and you know half the time I
never get to all of them yeah and at
some point you do have to have some
discipline like okay I got to stop
reading and start working yeah exactly
this actually gets some thing is there's
a lot of good there's a lot of high
quality content I mean a lot of these
articles I read they're great
beautifully written you know and well
researched and from you know a dozen
different sources and and it's like wow
that you know this is a big improvement
over in the amount of diversity of
voices we have now because the way you
know before the internet you know there
was so many filters you know
peer-reviewed journals and filters and
university presses have filters even
trade houses filters if nothing else
economic filters you know they like they
can only publish you know a couple dozen
books titles a year so they have to be
pretty selective so most people don't
get a voice well that's all changed
everybody has a voice now there's a lot
of crap out there but there's a lot of
really good writers I'm stunned yeah
it's a lifelong writer myself at how
good but the quality of so much writing
is yeah and also the instruction I want
to get into the kind of art of pedagogy
because you are also an instructor let
me go through your bio well while we're
starting yeah here because I don't want
to miss any any of the you know kind of
basic facts on the ground before we get
started so I'm going to say what I have
received from from you and your and your
PR firms and and publisher that dr.
Michael Shure yes that's right you've
got a crew you've got a whole zoom crew
dr. Michael Shermer is a presidential
fellow at Chapman University the
publisher of skeptic magazine and for 18
years was a month
columnist for Scientific American he's
the author of several New York Times
best-selling books including heavens on
earth the moral arc the believing brain
and why people believe weird things as
well as 12 other books thirteen other
books plus the one that he's writing
secretly while his hands are moving his
two TED Talks
have been viewed over nine million times
I got to think that's over ten million
by now when they were voted in the top
100 of the more than 2,000 TED Talks
that exists dr. Schurman received his BA
in Psychology from Pepperdine his MA and
experimental psychology from California
State University Fullerton and his PhD
in the history of science from Claremont
Graduate University he has a thriving
website you can connect to him there and
Michael Shermer comm you can also find
him prolifically posting on Twitter
tweeting away on Twitter at Michael
Shermer on Facebook at Michael Brant
Shermer and the thing that they left out
is sort of you know one of those we're
touching upon are some of the things you
do outside of your work you're a
prolific cyclist you were basically a
professional cyclist in some sense I
mean you competed in the race across
America and one of the first times I
ever came across you was in a book
called mistakes were made but not by us
I mean you're featured extensively in
that book and it's all about sort of the
theory and and psychology behind
cognitive dissonance --is and how they
are really insidious and how they
permeate fields ranging from psychology
to detective work by police who to
scientists in the physical sciences like
myself and in that book you were talking
about an event that really is the
intersection I think it's the kind of
the ultimate Shermer moment and I wanted
to you to maybe relate that really
quickly to the audience because you
shared with me in person but so you're
one of the few people I've met that has
been abducted by others
I saw the mothership now I actually I
used that story really to talk about
abductees who say you know I really
believe that you know this happened to
me and I say I believe you believe it in
other words I believe it's a real
experience people are having they are
not for the most part just making up
these crazy stories about UFOs and alien
to sell books maybe some do but I think
most of them you know really believe
this is the experience they've had that
book by the way mistakes were made but
not by me is by Carol tappers great book
I use it in my Chapman University course
skepticism 101 really effective that
it's sort of explaining how deceptive
our beliefs or how Mis misguided our
beliefs can become based on these
personal experiences that people had in
my case it was part of this race across
America which is a 3,000 mile nonstop
transcontinental bike race from LA to
New York different start and finish
points now but but in 1982 when he did
this we went LA to New York and and I
finished third and I broke the
transcontinental record and in 83 we
decided to do it again we had corporate
sponsors and ABC Wide World of Sports
was filming it so it's like okay I'm
just gonna do this for a while and
because there weren't any teaching jobs
there was a you know sort of a freeze on
hiring after prop 13 passed in
California so you know I wasn't gonna be
a full-time professor so I thought I'll
just be a full-time bike racer and you
know I'm in my 20s you know not married
no kids no house you know you're free to
do that sort of thing so I did so I
decided in 1983 I was gonna see if I
could ride all the way across the
country without sleeping at all and
because I read some research on sleep
deprivation and that there was some kid
who is like twenty one who went 11 days
without sleep at UCLA I thought okay and
Bayes across the country I can do that
it well I couldn't you know I made it
from the Santa Monica Pier to into
Nebraska and that was about 83 straight
hours and I just started hallucinating
like crazy
basically it was early in the morning
and early 4:00 a.m. something like this
so I'm kind of wobbling down the side of
the road about 6 miles an hour and my
bike and and every cyclist in this race
has a support crew that follows behind
them like a minivan and then a motor
home and and a support team so you don't
have to stop and go into hotels and
restaurants and things like that it's
just all on the fly that's how they can
do it quickly anyway so but at that
moment I just had this apparently had
this flashback to a childhood television
show called the invader starring Roy
Thinnes where the
aliens were invading earth but they were
taking over the bodies of humans and
looked just like them so this kind of a
Body Snatchers kind of mean and but but
but in the show they could tell that
they were aliens cuz they had a stiff
little finger which is really weird
because you know if alien traversed the
vast distances of interstellar space and
figure out genetic engineering and clone
humans but it's really their
intelligence in size but they couldn't
figure out the tendons and the little
finger I mean anyway crazy but but
that's what I thought on the side of the
road that my support team were these
aliens that look just like people I know
but I knew that they were actually these
Body Snatcher aliens and they're trying
to get me into the UFO which is just my
motor home and and apparently this
conversation went on for some time or
they're going come on sure Moritz break
that map and I'm like oh no and I'm
quizzing them like my girlfriend was on
the crew I was you know quizzing her
about personal details of our
relationship and the aliens knew all
this I was really impressed with this
anyway so then I took a 90-minute nap
and you know snapped out of it and
there's actually footage if you type in
Michael Shermer comma alien abduction
you'll see Eric Hyden the Olympic leader
who was a color commentator for a wide
world of sports interviewing me on and
I'm crossing the Mississippi bridge it
was midnight six and a half hours after
law and Haldeman's crossing when Michael
Shermer reached the Mississippi what
Diana and I hadn't known when we spoke
of a close race earlier was that Shermer
was slowing down as he told Erik hiding
there on the bridge he was wasted
that's a very very strange thing I mean
like psychotic Technic spirits but yeah
I thinking my crew was aliens from
another planet trying to capture me how
ridiculous he was still in second place
but he was floundering
but the point of that story really is
that first of all personal experiences
can be so powerful that they overwhelm
you know rationality that is I meet a
lot of people who claim you know I I'm
on border to you about the psychic
Sandhya's piano it's all [ __ ] now
that's I'm a skeptic new I love science
but I had this incredible experience let
me tell you about it then they'll tell
me about it and they go so I think there
might be something to this this one
thing that happened to me like okay
that's the power of right variants like
eben Alexander he wrote that book proof
of heaven yes you know he proof that's a
strong word in science proof evidence I
mean social scientists never used that
word maybe you guys do in the physics
you know proof well he went there you
know okay so and you you know you drill
down in the story you know he had the
you know brain brain virus and they put
him in an induced coma because his brain
was swelling anyway they started to
bring him out and he had this fantastic
hallucination that he thinks you know he
went to heaven now he knows you know
he's a neural he's a neurologist he
knows more about the brain that I do he
knows everything I know about near-death
experiences and trauma this and that but
it happened to him mmm and that's what
made it different it's very powerful
those experiences that are personal and
actually there's there something to be
said for personal experiences and the
end of this book giving the devil is do
know out by Michael Shermer there's
wonderful recollections of your and and
rather unvarnished so of your personal
interactions your personal experiences
with people that have taken on a
mythological stance in society ranging
from Richard Dawkins out to the late
great Christopher Hitchens and I think
it's it's it's and Jordan Peterson of
course
you've interacted with as well and I
think I think I want to take this
opportunity to kind of step back for a
second and focus on on the book itself
and we'll get to those interesting
intellectuals as we proceed but but I
first want to start with that with the
title of the book and actually the cover
of the book so I unlike what the common
cloak of advice is I always judge books
by the cover in fact I almost
exclusively will not even interested in
a book if I don't like the cover and on
the cover we have a quote from none
other than Richard Dawkins you may
disagree with Michael Shermer but you'd
better have a good reason and you'll
have your work cut out finding it now
this book I mean it's interesting he
talks about disagreeing with you this
book is not really a polemic of sorts
it's really sort of a compendium of your
greatest hits sort of updated for you
know updated and brought brought to you
know modernity some of them take place
quite quite a long time ago and really
in a cohesive source it's sort of a not
autobiography of you in a sense although
help you will someday write a proper
autobiography because I think that would
be warranted I'm gonna write an
unauthorized autobiography yeah and they
could be like Charles Barkley who
reportedly said once that he was missed
he was he was taken out of context and
they said it was your autobiography I
was misquoted it was you said it giving
the devil is do so yeah so the title
really is is it comes from this this
play a man for all seasons you know this
sort of collision between Thomas More
and King Henry the eighth over his
divorce from Catherine of Aragon and is
divorced from the Catholic Church and
fourth anyway in the play was defending
the law and that you know we need laws
that are fair and just for everybody and
his you know opponent is saying well we
got to cut down the laws to get after
the devil you know the bad guys and so
he was reportedly responsive this like
whoa but then when the laws are all cut
down and they turn the power turns on
you where are you going to go you know
you have no protection so we have to
give the devil is do
for our own safety sake and my case my
Devils are who is the devil it's anyone
who you disagree with who disagrees with
you thinks differently from you
you know how'd you know free speech is
for people that we don't like that's
what First Amendment is for people that
you know are saying things we don't want
to hear that's that that's the whole
reason for it it's not to protect people
so the devil is really just anybody
that's different from you disagrees with
you and so on and the reason we have to
give them their due
give them their free speech ultimately
if we have censorship laws then those
laws could be used against us when we're
in the minority when we're outside in
the window looking and wanting to have a
voice and you know that you know I give
some brief history of the First
Amendment in the introductions really
starting with the shank case in 1919
when Oliver Wendell Holmes wrote his
official position statement the you know
the the in which he said you know
shouting fire in a crowded theater would
be an example of a clear and present
danger that Congress is you know has a
right to censor because this could lead
to harm well what was this clearing
president winger at the equivalent of
shouting fire in a crowded theater in
1919 well it was this guy shank who was
a socialist in Philadelphia who was
handing out flyers to young men who were
a draft age as America was about to
enter the great war mm-hmm
so I mean Daria it's like wait you're
protesting the draft and this is
considered to be you know it's so
dangerous we have to censor it yeah and
and so at the moment this is the problem
well mama you you make that argument and
the argument could be made yeah this
could lead to this this this before you
know we don't have an army so we can't
defend ourselves so in the national
interest we have to you know protect
people from hearing criticisms of the
draft okay the problem with that is that
that you know that anybody speech could
be justified as needing to be censored
because you could make an argument for
almost anything what this is somehow
going to harm the nation or some
particular group or me in particular or
whatever and you know so the
as I say one man's hate speech is
another man's free speech and that in
the and the eve of the Civil War a lot
of pro-slavery proponents argued that
abolitionist speech that is northerners
coming down to southern states or
sending their literature you know are
publishing
magazine articles on promoting the
abolition of slavery was considered hate
speech no they didn't use that phrase
hate speech but they but the argument
that they made was this could lead to
slave revolts because if the slaves get
word of these arguments they may not
like being slaves anymore and and then
what's gonna happen they're gonna start
killing the white people and then you
know so we have to protect our citizens
from hearing this abolitionist speech
Wow and the same thing happened during
the civil rights movement with Bart
Luther King the reason he went to the
south is because he targeted the most
racist cities he could find so that it
would get media attention so that he
could get it challenged in the law and
ultimately the Supreme Court and and so
people then made the argument you know
this this guy is
I mean he's not as bad as Malcolm X but
this kind of stuff he's saying could
lead to riots inner-city riots and that
leads to violence therefore he should be
censored our ears you know
today and in 2020 you know using the
n-word calling women this or Jews that
or whatever that's hateful and we
shouldn't do it well I agree you know
don't be a dick shouldn't say things
like that right
but the moment you pass a law this is
okay we are not going to censor the
kinds of things that you know that that
challenge gender identity or whatever
the popular thing is right you know in
20 years 50 years you know those laws
are still on the books yeah and then
they get applied to something else we
can't even think what so as a general
principle I'm pretty much a free speech
fundamentalist yeah you're sort of
remarkable because you do it was one set
of by our mutual friend Sir Roger
Penrose about about Stephen Hawking that
you know it was no matter what you
believed you would you're an agreement
with Stephen Hawking because he would
often take opposite sides of the same
position and I see you as sort of you
know this radical extreme
libertarian you know that you're you are
you don't cleave to either political
party and I actually pride myself in
this podcast I always say you know as an
astronomer the reason I people love
astronomy is that there's no Republican
constellation or Democrat comment over
there and so it's apolitical by nature
you talk about funding and yeah maybe
some climate stuff here and there but in
astronomy per se it's mostly liberated
from that and that's why I like about it
so I don't talk too much about politics
except to say that this book like many
of your other books the title is sort of
a double entendre and I look at the at
the moral arc and I think about what you
were just saying with regard to you know
the shifting a legal zeitgeist of what
constitutes speech and and harm and
endanger etcetera and you make the point
in the book you know that Jordan
Peterson this famous case in Canada well
his his you know right to free speech
isn't as guarded perhaps as it is in
America and he's very controversial of
course but he did you know free speech
laws when they're enacted they're they
come with the full backing of a
government which you point out could be
physically punishable I mean you could
actually get punished at the end of a
gun for speech and perhaps even for a
thought and I wonder you've given so
many talks at campuses you're a
professor you teach on college campuses
have you seen the declination or the
Klein rather of of the tolerance and
freedom of speech at the places where as
freedom of speech used to be synonymous
with UC Berkeley and other places can
you comment on that and that'll be like
political sort of campus politics it's
okay to talk about politics I mean in a
way that's where the free speech is most
applicable because you guys will hash
out your your differences in some
astronomical theory in the journals and
conferences and books and debates and so
on and it kind of gets settled in the
long run
because I remember when I was and
started college in 72 the Big Bang
Theory I just kind of won out over the
steady state theory and and that's when
I first noticed I so there is kind of a
sense of progress like we have these
different theories but at some point it
gets settled like that's the
in politics is so messy and complicated
that there may not be a right answer
right it's like what's the right tax
rate well you know you know an abortion
very complicated gun is very complicated
so if any place you need sort of open
debate and disputation everybody their
position out on the table so we kind of
see where it all stands and so the
problem Canada like within France
Germany Austria Switzerland and a few
other countries Holocaust denial for
example is illegal yes Canada it's
illegal under the destroy hate speech
umbrella but that is speech that could
incite people to commit violence against
a particular group yes so so amazingly
it's actually illegal you could be
arrested for giving a lecture saying I
don't think six million people die now
they now AI make two that is let's say
I'm a historian of Native American
history in the United States and we want
to know how many people Native Americans
died at the hands of Europeans since
1492 okay well this is an actual field
of study you know how many people were
here before you know when with in 1492
well we don't know but you know ninety
million 70 million 50 million it's
debatable and and then how many died by
disease versus by you know guns and and
steel and it doesn't herbs and steel
sense of Jared Diamond's book title and
and that's disputed and but let's say
it's 50 million but but now let's say I
publishing a journal article or a book
in which I say you know what I don't
think so I think it was more like ten
million am I am i a holocaust denier
right be arrested for giving my argument
okay
now that said you know most of the
Holocaust deniers I've met you know
they're pretty Ferengi and they probably
are mostly anti-semitic you know but
that that aside they have arguments and
if we if you can't counter their
arguments if you're counter to their
argument tons but some specific thing
about Auschwitz is well you're a Nazi
that's not a counter that's not a
counter-argument and and so if anything
the principle you know sunshine is the
best disinfectant you know I I go the
opposite direction let them have their
say let's let's publish it you know
we did that in skeptic here that you
know 15 things at Holocaust revisionists
as they like to be called this is their
arguments these are their best arguments
and here's why they're wrong we did the
same thing with creationist climate
deniers and so on and ultimately I like
to think anyway is in your science it
gets kind of settled at some point it's
debatable this or that but then we kind
of get a refined argument and anyone
that's not going along with it
they're like the handful of people that
still claim the big bang didn't happen I
know there's these big Genesis right
here it's flat or whatever it's like
okay we don't have to worry about them
because you know so fringy but the way
we got there was through examining their
claims and so I applied that everywhere
and as I wrote in the book I actually
wrote a letter in defense of David
Irving to the judge in his trial in
Austria mainly because it was so
outrageous he this is not even a speech
crime this was a thought crime he got
arrested at the airport he flew from
London to Vienna and as they scanned his
passport it came up it was flagged as
one of these you know sort of dangerous
characters and he was just going to give
a speech about the Second World War
now I know his angle the Second World
you know Hitler was a pretty good guy
and he didn't know about some of the bad
stuff and so okay this is all [ __ ]
but the fact that that he gets arrested
for this thinking I thought was he had
given a speech he was just thinking
about giving his speech so are we
talking about an Orwellian thoughtcrime
yes that's what we're talking about so
you know Jordan's point there with that
bill c16 in Canada
it sounds good from like one of a
liberal perspective of the moral arc and
all that stuff yeah we should we should
be called people by them they want to be
called okay fine
I tell a little story in the book about
when I was in college at Pepperdine won
one semester my roommate was a guy named
Wayne I'd known him from high school he
hated his name all right so he changed
his name to d'Artagnan you know the
fourth musketeer but eventually
shortened it to DAR and I still talk to
him and we call him dark and he said you
know I'd like you to call me this we're
like what really d'Artagnan you know and
he got his driver's license changes and
the whole thing and we're like okay
we'll do it but you know just a friend
one on one asking you you know please
call me this is one thing you know don't
be a dick just do it
you know be a nice person
but then going to the government to say
we want you to force that guy to call
you that name that's different and I
supported you know Jordan's position on
that to the extent that that's the case
something like a gender pronoun not used
by say a government agency or a
university department or a corporation
would end up with some kind of trial or
some sort of conviction that I can't
speak to but in principle he's right
mm-hmm yeah and the right as you say the
devil is someone that you have potential
not to agree with on everything or maybe
on any one thing but that person is do
this sort of courtesy that you'd like
extend it to yourself so sort of a very
into the silver rule if not the golden
rule let me just take a break and ask
you what is the meaning the cover is
really cool it has sort of this very
three-dimensional shape to it actually
looks three-dimensional in the back
actually the covers behind you look even
more three-dimensional so what is the
meaning I I can see the pawn I can see
the devil but what's that what's the
symbolism going on there well the we
went through a couple of cover choices
and you know how this works
yeah and oh I need to claim it sorry
yeah actually let me just turn off my
phone where we're talking so the the
symbolism is is of course there's the
thing that you see you know the person
and then there's you know maybe behind
that there there secretly the devil and
you know it's not these people we have
to give the the you know the rights to
it's it's it's the shadow ones the you
know the ones that you know have the
horns and so on at least we think they
have the horns right you know and if you
look at the long history of free speech
you know it's it's been a battle pretty
much for the last several thousand years
and the reason is because governments
and autocrats theocrats they don't want
to give people the opportunity to
dissent because the centers cause
friction fractions and power structures
the whole point of having a free press
is is to allow dissent and we now know
from studies of the Nazi era that you
know they never had a majority of course
when they were elected in 1933 they were
alone
right they were elected but it was a
minority position okay fine
that happens in a lot of elections and
like an angular Merkel always has to
make these coalition's with different
parties because in Germany there's so
many different parties but the question
was is I've always pursued is how do you
get how do you convert an entire group
of people educated cultured you know the
land of Beethoven and Goethe you know
intelligent people to become Nazis and
the answer appears to be well they
didn't most of them didn't go along with
the Nazi ideology now there was rampant
anti-semitism but there was
anti-semitism throughout most European
countries it wasn't necessarily worse in
Germany then then say France or Poland
particularly Russia
you know there's Hitler's willing
executioner's is Daniel Kohlberg
Goldhagen called his book there was a
lot of them around but the general
population while they may not have liked
you they were not extermination
astrology's and beliefs I've gotten to
the point where now I I'm willing to say
no Hitler no Holocaust and probably even
no Hitler no World War two yeah yeah you
know the people weren't that bad and so
but how did they maintain power for so
long
two things one pluralistic ignorance
where every viral of silence where
everybody thinks everybody else thinks
some people don't well why don't they
know that the others because the
censorship of dissenters who would say
the emperor has no clothes did you
notice that he's naked and if nobody can
say that then you know everybody you
know falls into this spiral of silence
and that's why autocrats want us you
know jail and censor jail in prison
whatever the Gulag Archipelago and the
kale concentration system in germany and
punish North Korea now and and so on so
you know us free speech fundamentalist
weak you know we want to push back the
moment any government starts to go down
that road because they always do almost
like it's a law of nature yeah your
physical laws that yeah this is what
governments do so you know it we didn't
know about what our own government was
doing even Democrats like Kennedy and
Johnson until the Pentagon Papers right
you know and and now with WikiLeaks you
know a lot of this crazy stuff that
started with Bush
at the Homeland Security and all that
but but but Obama was just as bad as
Bush and so it's almost like you know
you get in there and they go okay here's
what's really going on oh well we got to
silence these people we got to do this
we got to do that all right so right so
on the eve of the release of giving the
devil his due we're in April early April
of 2020 we're both in California and
we're under form of self-isolation and
so-called sheltering in place not not a
quarantine per se and not a true
lockdown but we're you know demanded at
some to some level you know not even to
go to the beach and walk on and nature
trails and so it's really unprecedented
in my lifetime and I'm sure in your
lifetime - or not yeah how much
different age but but one of the things
you know initially I reacted kind of
cynically at it when they it was it was
the governor ordered that this and I
should speak carefully because he is my
boss after all but the governor Newsom
the wise and brilliant governor Newsom
you know didn't make this edict apply to
the press and that's you know he's just
taking care of this fawning press that
you know we all love and I've got many
friends that are in the newspaper
business but but then I came to
immediately realize that it just as you
say this media is so critical to the to
the reportage of truth and to checking
on power but I want to get your
impression now we have the sort of micro
media which are these you know bloggers
and Twitter you know you know people
people on Twitter and Facebook etc that
can really overwhelm and sort of storms
of attrition Wars of attrition through
their you know voice their opinions and
it could be something I agree with it
could be something I don't agree with I
mean obviously there are certain really
abhorrent viewpoints on Twitter and
elsewhere but but there is also this
potential now not for governments to
really police speech but really the so
called cancel culture that you talk
about a little bit in the book and how
anathema that is to the free you know
the dissemination of information so I
wonder if you can talk about that and
why is it so prevalent on college
campuses why do you get cancelled from
invitations or people like our mutual
friend Ben Shapiro and and and other
people that you've had on your show and
cars
with like jordan peterson that you know
i don't know personally but but why is
this more prevalent on campus than say
by governments you know and in the past
would be some government suppressing ben
shapiro or you know someone else right
or even decades ago as conservatives
that were more in favor of censorship
and liberals that were champions of free
speech I mean the ACLU has always been
considered kind of a liberal
left-leaning
organization and ok so there's different
ideas you know floating around about
this I have a chapter in the book called
what went wrong you know I think there's
several things first you know if we
trace it back to the civil rights
movement that begins with sense being
sensitive to speech well because words
matter and words can be hurtful and you
know just pick the most obvious one
using the n-word you know I won't do it
I don't even want to do it in print I
don't want to say the word you know and
and I'm and I'm an okay baby boomer I'm
you know I'm 65 and you know so we've
all been inculcated into this that
language is harmful and we shouldn't do
it mm-hmm and so from there you go well
what other words you know should we not
be using besides the n-word well you
shouldn't call women the c-word
and-and-and call Jews [ __ ] and on and
on yeah yeah I agree with that you know
and that starts expanding now in in a
good way we all shift our language in
the way we speak to each other
informally you know television scripts
movie scripts what the what the
characters and movies and films and
novels say that's all change you can
track when a novel was written or when a
movie was done you know just down to the
decade sometimes even a year based on
the kind of words that are used to talk
about women blacks and Jews for example
all that is good but then the moment you
you introduce like affirmative action
laws and and anti-discrimination laws
and so on then it's easy to suck into
that the words that people use and
pretty soon you're policing language and
then it because and then we got to
punish the transgressors and so this
happened over many decades I saw it
happening when I was you know in a
college student and then in the 80s when
I started to be
you know I saw the speech codes but you
know becoming broader you know sort of
concept creep
well category gets bigger right things
that you know that can't be said or
shouldn't be said and then the
enforcement levers not just like say
government anti speech codes those are
harder to get past but the the kind of
norming of silencing leads people to
self-censor
so while you know like a Chapman
University where I teach you know if I
ask students how many of you self-censor
on a lot of these sensitive subjects
about you know race and gender and so on
every hand goes up that you know they're
all afraid to say what they really think
and and this is more dangerous than a
law that you can pinpoint go that that
law is unconstitutional we need to
overturn that law let's have a court
case about it that you can kind of is
more tangible but this sort of subtle
bottom-up you know no one wants to say
anything because they're afraid because
the norms have changed that's what's
more dangerous and so you know I then
there's a few other factors that again
with this totally reasonable liberal
idea of diversity is good
I agree diversity is good and I'd like
to see more black faces and more women
and more Jews and more Hispanics and so
on this is all good but but then when
you start to enforce it and you leave
out viewpoint diversity you know maybe
we need some more conservatives in our
department what you know it's like okay
so maybe you're not that in favor of all
kinds of diversity and and so on so that
was another factor leading to that and
and I think you know the media's kind of
gone along with that the Academy's gone
along with it and now all those college
students in the 60s and 70s they're you
know tenured professors now their Dean's
their presidents of universities they're
making policy and you could see that
from that historical trajectory there
was a kind of a logic to it but you know
it's still I think just went went too
far yeah yeah and then it sort of you
know worrisome to me because I have come
to feel that universities are these real
Citadel's of you know truth and and
of course in the in the heart science is
there's a little bit of a you know
different sort of standard as you were
talking earlier is there proof no we
don't really talk about proof we mainly
talk about this proof and maybe someone
that carries over the Social Sciences
because you you're entitled to your
viewpoint I'm entitled to my viewpoint
you can't prove either one and maybe I
could dispute yours and of course the
famous quote you know that you know I
may disagree with you but I'll fight to
the death for your right to say it so
you know in this book you do take you
know I write down I always write
imaginary blurbs you know as if you'd
ever asked me to write you a blur but oh
you're next you're next for the next
book I hope so but I call you the
conductor in the orchestra of cognitive
dissonance that really makes the melody
shine so you really have this unique
ability to take to really see with with
care you know once I was talking to a
friend about you and your work before I
went on your show and he was you know he
was saying you know Michael just sees
everything through these lenses and I
feel like you see that through the lens
of exactly don't you know you look at
polarization which not the kind that I
study and the light from the ancient
universe but but your current you know
that where we talk about how ideas can
be so disjoint and and yet we should
have a sense of compassion and I feel
that you you really exemplify that and I
should also point out that you made your
lectures for your Chapman course they're
available on YouTube on your channel and
I urge people to look at that to see
that compassion is our mutual friend
Heather McDonald says teaching is an act
of love and I think you can't you can't
convince somebody of a point you can't
teach somebody a point on not not has to
be platonic obviously but but you can't
convince something of something if you
hate them if you know that you have this
displeasure for somebody and what makes
what makes communication and teaching
and learning possible as a sense of
safety so in the book you talk about you
kind of bring down your own version of
how I like to say you know how you would
govern the world almost not not governed
planet Earth though govern a different
world over ours that we experience from
a distance but it's looking more and
more attractive Oh although I do joke
recently on Twitter I tweeted about how
you remember back in 2013
there was this company that was selling
rides to Mars and it's gonna be a you
know a one-way trip and the voyage
itself in complete isolation would be
you know two years perhaps just based on
the limits of space travel and there
were over 10,000 people signed up like
my friend Elizabeth Landau did a did a
nice piece on this and CNN for CNN and
she said that 10,000 people paid like 40
or 50 bucks to get in this list and then
the company went out of business or what
but I'm wondering you know how many
people nowadays do you think would sign
up for that kind of isolation and what
is it about the mind that you know you
really don't know what you have until
it's gone and and I worry about that for
you know having this discourse but let's
talk about the astronomical let's talk
about governing more so there's a famous
exchange about two years ago between you
and Elon Musk's yeah govern Mars I'll
just say that the title of years chapter
14 governing Mars lessons from the Red
Planet from experiments governing the
blue planet yeah so well he was you know
tweeting about this as Elon is want to
do and I find him such an inspirational
figure of our time to even think about
doing this like you know what we're
gonna do this we're gonna go to Mars oh
okay I mean that's how things big things
happen it starts with an idea okay fine
but but in my world that ki I don't I
don't work in the physical sciences so I
don't know how to get there by Rockets
or whatever and what kind of structure
we need and how to grow food there
potatoes or whatever but you know in
terms of a social structure a moral you
know a moral system some you know I've
always been curious is a sci-fi scenario
you know if you know if you send a bunch
of atheist to Mars and came back
centuries later would they all have
something like religion and some belief
in a god something like that or and or
if you just sent people that knew
nothing about politics would they end up
with something like a democracy or they
knew nothing about economics would they
end up with something like a regulated
free market economy you know something
like that you know what I'm after there
is you know deeper principles of human
nature that emerged no matter what kind
of social situation you have so then I
started thinking well what kind of
government would we set up no possible
inocentes social engineers up there and
they'll think of something no one has
ever thought of before
and okay that would be great then we
could we could transport it back to
earth like hey you guys should try this
here it works it works on Mars it works
on Mars with 20 people yeah well try it
with 20 million you know and therein
lies the problem is the you know you can
have a direct democracy with you know
with a couple dozen people maybe in like
a university department where everybody
votes on something and you all know each
other but the problem is is you know the
complications multiplied you know
geometrically as the numbers population
numbers go up and so the potential for
conflict was a human diversity of
different interests and needs there is
no one system there is no utopia and
it's a dangerous idea to think we can
design the perfect society there's no
perfect society you know so you have to
have an open-ended experimental system
so I'm inspired by science in this sense
that Sagan makes this point in his
demon-haunted world but but but but
never sinned it's all experiments from
like you can collect data so let's say
you have 50 different states with
different constitutions and they and
they have 50 different say gun control
regulations well those are experiments
now we can look at and try to you know
control intervening variables and see
what the effects of say gun control laws
are or are not and now this is
complicated and hard and different
social scientists have different
conclusions from the same data set and
some of its ideologically driven others
or not but the point is that these are
experiments if you started off with a
direct democracy on Mars with you know
say a dozen astronauts there you know
what happens when it gets to you know a
hundred dozen or you know a thousand
thousand or a million people you know
then then you I contend you're going to
end up with something like a
representative democracy a
constitutional republic like we have
because we've been running these
experiments on earth for thousands of
years and many experiments have been
tried most fail you know the theocracies
autocracies dictatorships various you
know command economies you know they
just don't work and it's not that our
system is perfect you know it's just but
but it works better than some of these
others mmm-hmm anyway so the idea there
is
let's look around to see what has worked
here and take it with us to Mars or at
least a start now it turns out when I
was researching there's other people
like Carl's cocktail the chemical
biologists physicists I think in England
is you know written quite a bit about
this and that it could be you know
having multiple sources of oxygen and
water and food because we have to
remember that it's the the analogue of
Europeans coming to North America it
doesn't work because they had bad air
they had water bad food on the hoof and
in the in the streams and you know our
Martians aren't going to have anything
to start with so the idea that an
autocrat can get control of the air
production or water production you know
that's really dangerous so you know
Charles's
solution is that multiple almost like
multiple companies and multiple agencies
are instead of a centralized control and
command system you have many so no
monopolies don't can have a monopoly I
explore some of that in that chapter
just because it's a super interesting
idea and then look at other earthly
experiments which I got from Nicholas
Christakis his book blueprint where he I
didn't even know there was a data set of
people that study shipwreck survivors
and how they survive now the ones that
shipwrecked and didn't survive we don't
know what happened because they're dead
but the ones that so it's a fairly
narrow data set you know the ones that
you know shipwrecked survived and we're
rescued to tell somebody what happened
right there's some bias selection bias
yeah definitely but but it is a kind of
experiment these are called natural
experiments you know we can't control
marriages and divorces but we can see
what happened with marriages and
divorces after the fact and look at what
different laws about marriage and
divorce effect you know in childhood
whatever these are natural experiments
that you couldn't actually run but they
happen anyway
so in the case of the shipwrecks it
turns out more egalitarian or sort of
horizontal control structures where
everyone has an equal voice you know
works better than a hierarchical
military type command structure which is
what most of these Navy ships were yeah
but but when they got to the island and
they're just trying to survive that
it turns out those kind of command
structure didn't work those vertical
ones didn't work as well it's just kind
of a yeah maybe a small lesson for you
know structuring things that are more
horizontal giving people a voice
somewhere which is what you know
democracies do better than autocracy
yeah yeah yeah so that I've come into
contact with that not personally myself
but my research as you know in part is
conducted at the South Pole Antarctica
where there's isolation you know
complete isolation for about nine months
of the year and the National Science
Foundation has done psychological
research studies on among other things
you know what's the optimum ratio of of
men and women and that doesn't rely on
you know stuff from shipwrecks from you
know going to ancient Tahiti or
something like that that's modern-day
human being so yeah I think there's some
interesting parallels like what do they
say about that I believe that the ideal
ratio is about two men for every woman
or at least this is again the don't hold
me to this but it was it was asymmetric
and I think there were more men than
women and I think the reason was it was
you know a hundred percent men that
would be that would be bad I think was
the decision because there be too much
aggression and frustration yeah it was
all women it would be fine but they
think they felt like you know they want
to see what could there be could there
be some men and women together and then
if there's 50/50 then a man might feel
and you're much more qualified to you
know look at the psychological aspects
but if there's 50/50 then you feel like
well I should have you know a partner or
say you know a female friend down here
and I don't and so it would lead to some
stress or something
again nobody hold me to this on the
internet don't send me email but there
the NSF has done social science
experiments with the ideal you know kind
of societies at the South Pole and you
know it's it's it's also the kind of
ideal place to go to if you want to
escape from the Mafia or you know or
your credit-card company and I can't
always say which is worse
but you quote it from there from to I
don't know if you knew this but two very
esteemed you know people are quoted
within inches of one another Kim Stanley
Robinson and David Brin both of them
were my friends at both of them are UCSD
alum and in fact we have a rich
tradition with the Benford brothers
David Brin Kim Stan
Robinson others but you you also discuss
with him and I'll be speaking with him
next week by the time my listeners hear
that's probably two weeks from now but
I'll be speaking with David about his
ideas for possible benefits that come
out of the kovat situation because it
may not be all negative there may be
radical transformations both for good
and bad but he does describe in the book
I think it's it's pretty interesting the
different types of constituencies and
and how you would do this balloting and
and how how such things could work and
then also Kim Stanley Robinson who has
the Mars trilogy very famous red Mars
green Mars blue Mars fascinating science
fiction trilogy he talks about the
different types of resources and
commodities and companies and cultures
that might pervade in the future and I
wondered you know you you're not a
science fiction writer but you kind of
you know you have some friends that are
science fiction writers as I do what is
the value in arthur c clarke obviously
is science fiction as well as in a
science writer himself what is it about
science fiction that allows us to sort
of you know play what what Einstein used
to call Gedanken experiments you know
thought experiments of the future why
why is it so do you think do you feel
like I don't want to you know bias your
gear response but you know do you feel
it's been successful you feel like you
know the ways that we thought of things
I mean arthur c clarke is famous in 2001
for you know predicting many many things
but you know the same could be said of
the simpsons
you know they predicted about the track
rate including an episode about a virus
pandemic spread by cats which they call
the perfect the perfect storm anyway so
what is the value of science fiction's
and since our name said yeah that's
that's a great question really i think
the the more foundational answer would
begin with what's the value of
storytelling at all so there is a branch
of evolutionary psychology that you know
studies literature you know what why is
it certain themes come up over and over
and over and pretty much all great
novels and works of fiction we really
related to human nature you know power
struggles status sex you know all the
gossip that goes around what people are
doing and who's sleeping with who and
who you know who has power who's
who's honest who's deceptive you can
trust me you can't so there's never
Lucia many reasons why gossip is you
know structured around those particular
themes because they they really have a
lot of consequences for survival of both
individuals and group cohesiveness and
stories then are kind of tapping into
that those sort of gossip themes that
come up and over and over just think of
you know any of Shakespeare's plays or
Jane Austen's novels you know they're
very much about human relationships and
sex and power and so but but one theory
of the origins of storytelling is is is
that it's a it's a way of like a thought
experiment in your head of
counterfactual reasoning that helps you
understand causal relationships in the
real world by running them through your
head initially to see what you think
might happen before you actually do it
which could have real-world bad
consequences we out of the beam call
running the experiments you know because
like if I do this then she's gonna do
that if I say this then he'll say that
and and so on that it's a one theory
about the origin story telling is that
it's it's an involved mechanism for
social cohesiveness involving human
relationships and interactions that are
potentially a high in conflict so you
know just think of a Jane Austen novel
you get this kind of meta meta
structure of you know he thought that
she was going to think that he might go
to the dance with this woman instead of
but he knew that she was thinking that
he white dude you know and and that kind
of meta reasoning is is a kind of it's a
story but it's also a way of a thought
experiment like okay what should I do
down the line well I better like a Dutch
player back whatever moves to see which
the consequences will be with the first
move yeah so I think what client fiction
writers are doing is pretty much that
but they're doing it forward you know
into the future based on what we know
about science which of course that's why
I prefer science fiction to other forms
of fiction disclose you all love science
in a way it's a way of you know telling
a story about what could happen and I
find science fiction writers to be even
more prescient than scientists on a lot
of these things because they have to
work it out in a in a plot you know in
which you had character development and
plot development and a narrative arc
that has to go somewhere so science
fiction writers I think run those
thought experiments more carefully than
scientists do because they have to keep
a coherent narrative going that makes
sense to them and and therefore I think
people like arthur c clarke or david
brin and others you know or that they're
really well worth reading both their
fiction and their nonfiction because
even when they're writing but like when
David writes his nonfiction essays and
books David Brent you know I I know he's
really insightful in terms of creating
these fictional stories so he knows how
to think through a thought experiment
way down the line the consequences might
be so he's worth listening to do you
feel as David does and I do and that
there'll be positive outcomes that will
result from this awful pandemic that
we're experiencing obviously in every
life is infinitely precious but but will
there be any any bright spots well our
green shirts hang out hang on there we
don't think that every life is present
in other areas yeah you know in terms of
you know just the speed limit if you
wanted to reduce the carnage of
automobile deaths 35,000 a year reduce
the speed limit to 25 miles an hour
right well no way we're not doing that
okay well and then I guess life is not
infinitely precious right or limit
abortion you know yeah we make these
decisions all the time and you know
insurance companies they know the value
of a life because they have to pay out
or automobile companies that have to pay
off a settlement you know what's what's
the life what's the value of the life of
the person that was build mobile car or
whatever you know judges buries
insurance companies they put a price you
know it's like 1.3 million dollars per
life whatever so that's that's already
been done we do that all the time
and of course the thing we're in the
middle of right now is you know the
economic shutdown and and everyone's a
Toby young wrote an article about this
and got hammered on Twitter yesterday
for this just bringing it up like maybe
shutting down the economy and definitely
is not a good idea because people could
die from other causes having to do with
you know lack of food or or you know
housing you know and you know without
any income at all you can't pay your
bills and at what point now you get food
suicide there was a recession domestic
violence apparently is a little uptick
that in the last week or two so you know
it should be okay back to our free
speech it should be okay to bring that
up I get hammered as being you know
incensed it is instead of human life of
course we would all prefer nobody dies
from the coronavirus just like we would
nobody dies from the flu but people do
die of the flu and we're willing to you
know accept a certain level of that but
but because we're used to it mm-hmm
so in terms of you know silver lion you
know I don't know I suspect that
greetings will change you know what
we'll be doing the yoga bow or the
Japanese bow instead or maybe the elbow
bump rather than the handshake you know
that you know I don't care I can I can
live with that
you know you know as for other things I
don't think anybody knows it's too soon
to tell
yeah I always point out you know that I
believe that the origin of their
handshake with your right hand
originates from the fact that people
when they were armed the dominant armed
predominantly in society it was the
right hand so you're showing that you
weren't armed so you know what's better
what better outcome could there be yeah
I want to take a detour to talk about
back to book writing and your process
for we have a lot of writers we host the
clarion science fiction workshop every
summer at UCSD I believe this year will
be probably virtual but there might be
hope that it could be in person and
that's a you know a lot of listeners are
interested in your craft as a writer and
you got into this a little bit that you
that you write every day but can you
take us through like a normal day I mean
you're very busy as a professor you do
you know family obligation of young
young son at home as well as a home life
with your with your wife but but yeah so
what is your craft like how do you
actually maintain productivity III don't
really have a set schedule
all that much I pretty much write in the
afternoons I usually work out in the
mornings or take my dog for a hike and
go for a bike ride and take care of
business elsewhere and then you know for
a couple hours a day I try to write it
depends on of course where I'm at right
right now I'm just promoting this book
yeah I'm not writing another book
there's no secret life here no keyboard
here I'm writing the next book I'm
always thinking about what I should
write next and that depends on what
might be the market interest in such a
thing and I don't just mean marketing
other than money I mean reader interest
what do people care about and and and
then what am i passionate about what do
I really want to spend the next couple
years reading about thinking about
writing about talking about and so but
this to kind of take a bigger picture
you know I was always interested in the
big question so when I became a
born-again Christian I was 17 in high
school then I went to Pepperdine to
major in theology I was really
interested in a being a college
professor because it seemed like a great
gig right oh yeah
get paid to speak and write and talk and
think big ideas do you know what Neil
Armstrong did by the way after he came
back eventually after he came back from
landing on the moon what wasn't he a
professor at a college professor yeah
Cincinnati I think yeah yeah yes that's
right so that shows you we're in the
we're in a very steam profession right
III like the life you know it's great
and but but I think what was it going to
say about that you're talking about when
you graduate peppered after you're born
oh oh yeah so I was always interested in
the big questions like is there a god
you know what about free will and
determinism you know moral questions and
it seemed like the theologians were
really interested in these things I will
be a professor of theology right and
mmin at Pepperdine I found out you know
that well what do you got to do to be a
college professor you have to PhD what
do I have to do get PhD in theology well
you got a master Hebrew Greek Aramaic
and Latin and I could barely get through
Spanish I thought oh boy I got a switch
to something I could do which you know I
was you know I was pretty good at
science math statistics and so I went
into Social Sciences but I still like
the big ideas and
so when I abandoned religion for various
reasons I was still interested in okay
well what is the origin of the year why
is there something rather than nothing
is there a god or not why is the
universe finely tuned what is the basis
of consciousness where does our moral
sense come from you know are we strictly
electric meat determine like a machine
like a cockroach or we or is there some
element of freewill in there volition or
whatever all of those questions you know
all the way up to abortion and and
foreign policy and immigration and so on
I always try to bring to it a scientific
perspective from the secular perspective
because I don't believe anymore but I'm
still want to know well you know what's
the answer maybe there is an an answer
but you know what's my answer in my head
based on what other people think that
are harder than me mm-hmm
there's a lot of them so my writing is
pretty much around now you know why
people believe weird things was about
you know the paranormal supernatural and
so on so I debunked that and then how we
believe the second book was well what
about God so religious beliefs and so on
and then well if there's no God then
what about morality so the science of
good and evil is the third book and so
my book kind of build on just topics I
think are important that everybody's
interested in and that I care about that
I want to know what the answer is which
is why I you know I was really
appreciative of you correcting me on
some of the background on why there's
something rather than nothing you know I
just want to know I don't have an agenda
I just want to know what it was the
answer and if there's no answer okay
that's okay right
like the afterlife you know my previous
book heavens on earth oh I don't know
yeah I thought that bumper sticker once
it said militant agnostic I don't know
and you don't either
and that's right and I'll fight you to
the death for our media meeting that's
splitting the difference I want to talk
more about teaching as a professor so
let me first ask you a devilish question
do you think tenure is necessary now I'm
sitting here thank God I am a you know
professor of tenure long ago but and and
I don't take that for granted in the bed
I think it's the greatest I always say
it's the greatest three hour week job in
the world but no it's actually a lot
more than that as you know but
it's the autonomy that you have that's
right yeah it's the freedom to be an
intellect and I think that that vignette
that you were just mentioning that we
correspondent about you know miss miss
conceptions that that you might have had
I might have had I think a scholar is
such as yourself is distinguished by the
fact that he or she will be open to just
learning and to being a good student and
to that and I want to talk a little bit
about teaching and learning and but
first with that provocative question do
you feel that tenure is is necessary in
today's modern age do you think it's
it's a valuable it's the only you know
feel that that has permanent you know
one of my colleagues said be careful
when you hire somebody on a search
committee because you know it's not like
getting married you can always get
divorced but with tenure it's for life
whether you like it or not thank you of
all my colleagues I've never wanted
divorce a single one of them yeah but do
you think it's necessary in the physical
side are and the social signs and what's
your feeling well I I used to think it
was not necessary anymore because the
original reason to set it up was more
because of the fear of of right-wing
forces suppressing the speech of liberal
professors and that was the case say in
the forties and fifties yeah maybe into
the 60s but then that kind of all
loosened up and I thought well there's
really not much need for tenure anymore
I mean professors are pretty free to
speak and say whatever they want what's
the problem
now we have the opposite where you know
professors are censored by you know the
political correct you know social
justice activists and so on this whole
identity politics thing is causing a lot
of professors to have to go into the
closet if they I don't just mean
conservatives but I mean just centrists
or people that are critical of the far
left they feel like they could be under
attack
lose their jobs if they don't have
tenure so maybe we still need tenure I
don't know but I mean that's kind of a
broad question I think a simpler
solution would be just instead of it
being a social norm that everybody
practices like universities do whatever
they want much like law firms you know
that you you want to make you you want
to make partner that's kind of the goal
which is a kind of a tenure for lawyers
you know but it but and it's you know
wide and I think they've handled that
pretty well maybe but doctors don't have
the equivalent medical
don't have the equivalent a partnership
with that ownership of their practice
something like that it's slightly
different than tenure so I would say you
know leave it up to the universities to
decide you know what works for them
works with public universities and it's
more of a government decision but you
know what I mentioned I went to
Pepperdine you know it's a Church of
Christ school they don't acquired their
professors to swear by any faith as far
as I know you know and I would love to
teach there it's in Malibu you know it's
a beautiful campus it's much closer than
Chapman to me from Santa Barbara where I
live now but but you know it would be
their right to not hire me right right I
wouldn't feel like I was being
discriminated against not being hired
because it's in their mission statement
they you know they're a Christian
University why the hell would you hire
an atheist like me well maybe they want
to just as a you know devil's advocate
it's the people to teach their students
how the other side thinks affirmative
action yeah it's kind of different you
know diversity of permit of action I
suppose but I wouldn't feel like I was
being cheated out of a job opportunity
and being discriminated against because
that's that's their mission statement
right that's a private university so if
you applied to work at a Shiva
University in New York you're not a
rabbi it would be very different
although they have people that aren't
Jewish that are professors there so
right so you know belief but but you're
right it sort of be a you know be hard
harder to justify in some sense but I
still think it could make sense I mean
there are people I mean we have a
Nazarene school here Point Loma Nazarene
and San Diego I've been there to speak
beautiful campus also these these you
know these these Christian schools are
just so phenomenal but and but but yes I
think it's what interests me the most is
sort of your teaching style and one
thing that struck me as a professor and
maybe this is obvious to my
undergraduates but I was never taught
how to be a professor it's sort of you
know oh you're smart and you did some
you know abstract abstruse research so
you must be really good at teaching I
mean they're really different skills in
the metas skeletally stack utterly
different and so I want to know how can
you well I'm gonna get to my big
question which I asked all the thinkers
that come on my show later on but but
can you teach someone to be a good
teacher so
the question I'll ask later on is you
know can you teach someone to be
creative and this T is creativity inborn
or is it sort of or is it possible to
acquire I'll answer that at the end of
the show but but for now what about
teaching what are the necessary
ingredients to be a teacher that well I
think like most of us we just have
mentors that we admired that inspired us
as teachers like I'd like to be like
like that guy that like I really changed
my life that's how I felt like I want to
be like him now I think there's some
temperament to it I mean some people are
super shy super introverted you know
maybe they're gonna have a harder time
entertaining a you know a classroom full
of kids but that doesn't mean they can't
they have to be bad teachers they may be
boring but you can you can teach certain
skills like you know there's all sorts
of tutorials about how to build a proper
PowerPoint keynote presentation certain
do's and don'ts that that's pretty
straightforward but you know just sort
of the emotionally engaged professor
with students you know that's hard to
quantify right I mean some people have
it some people don't
yeah and you know I don't know how you
bottle that because that has to do with
more somebody's personality and we all
know there's a huge variation there
we've all had super inspirational
professors and other there it'll be
boring it is a little odd in the academy
that again you go through all these
training programs or how to be a
researcher like yeah in your case how to
be a professional scientist and
published in scholarly journals and and
you've had tons of instructions on that
as well as modeling and then then you
get hired they go okay now go teach no
one's ever told you well how do I do
that well you think back well I had this
great professor I'm gonna do what he did
sort of all you can do is model well
what I found so interesting is and I
think it's the only place in the entire
you know there's a Federal Register of
approved documents so it includes you
know like the handbook for working I
don't know at the IRS you know
collecting taxes it's a handbook for
this and there's a handbook because
flight instruction it requires a federal
certification so in the whole hierarchy
of government you know jobs and
bean-counters f/22 you know tax
collectors to whatever Centers for
Disease Control workers there is a
single instance of Maslow's hierarchy of
needs and it occurs in the flight
instructors handbook from the Federal
Aviation Administration I'm studying to
become a flight instructor I'm a
commercial pilot I fly a lot as you know
and one thing I'd love to you know kind
of pick your brain on is we don't even
get like the remedial sense of this now
in an airplane cockpit you know I've
known for because I had to be a student
and to become an instructor you have to
be a student you have to be a pilot you
have to be commercially rated etc etc it
still doesn't guarantee you could be a
good teacher you could be Chuck Yeager
he might not have been a great flight
instructor but nevertheless there's sort
of a basic level of the understanding of
needs and purpose and I'd like to
connect that to chapter 10 in your book
does the universe have a purpose and
it's subtitle is alvey's error and the
meaning of life so those of you who will
remember the wonderful film Annie Hall
there's a character Alvey singer who's
Woody Allen's character and he's another
devil right I mean what Eon has to be a
devil nowadays no but anyway he
complains to his doctor the you know his
mother comes to take him to a
psychiatrist and says he he complains to
the doctor the universe is expanding
well the universe is expanding and if
it's expanding someday it'll break apart
and I'll be the end of everything
his exasperated mother upgrades the
youth what is that the universe got to
do with it you're here in Brooklyn
Brooklyn's not expanding and so you call
this
alvey's earth and that's the error you
know sort of ascribing teleological
meaning and purpose to life and you you
and I have this interests connection
that they were both sort of irritated in
a good way by the famous theologian
William Lane Craig and in fact the only
reason I was on Ben Shapiro show is that
William Lane Craig was on a show and I
wanted to kind of point out some of the
category errors and and other you know
their claims that he had made that I
found the suspect and wanted to sort of
correct namely you know this kind of
first cause it's always the same with
with theologians you know which which I
have great respect for you know that the
universe must have had a beginner and
because it must have had a beginner you
know that to suggest a designer creator
came into existence nothing that exists
well the cosmological argument and then
it goes to the but it always ends up
with Jesus and
as a practice and Jew you know I wanted
to kind of take it take the angle and
get into that from from a Jewish
perspective so that was my you know it
was my take on things that I discussed
with Ben on his show and actually you
were one of Ben's first guests back in
episode 6 of his show and you discussed
the multi-verse etcetera and actually I
had Ben gave me a shout out during that
episode that they would have to consult
to me and that was that was really cute
to be associated but I want to talk
about this notion of purpose and and you
talked about
alvey's errors so so can you describe
what you mean by alvey's error and yeah
well you mentioned that category or is
it or you might call it a levels error
that you know the theologian is
operating at some longtime scale like
you know it like Craig argued if it if
in a billion years from now there's no
earth and and in 20 billion years the
universe will be gone whatever what
difference does it make how I treat
somebody tomorrow you know wrong level
okay it matters to the person being
affected by you tomorrow
it matters to me how I'm treated it I
don't care if in a billion I'm not
living a billion years from now you know
I live in Brooklyn the universe Brooklyn
is not expanding right so and that that
kind of air pervades a lot of just
common thinking about what's the purpose
of life I think most people haven't that
much thought when they did sort of
inculcate what we were raised with
usually their religion because you know
religion has sort of had a monopoly on
this question and scientists were
supposed to stay out of that you know
non-overlapping magisteria noma yeah you
know Gould famous Noma you know that's
none of your business scientists you
know this is what theologians stay in
your lane in your lane right well I
think this is crazy of course the
scientist would say about this and even
if you end up in at some epistemological
wall say this between you and William
Lane Craig and what you mean by the
first moment or what was there before
the Big Bang and you know at some point
the further back we go we're just going
to hit a wall there's nothing more to
say we just don't know anymore or even
some concepts like I will toggle within
that chapter on why there's something
rather than nothing would you virtually
correct me on some point but this the
idea of nothing you know if you if you
keep
drilling down to the nothing you know
you not just know stuff in the universe
those stars and planets and people and
so on but no light no space and time
there's not even darkness because
darkness would imply that there's light
somewhere but there can't there's no
light so there's no darkness and there's
not even nothing to be nothing I mean
it's just a word we use and and
therefore there's also no platonic
categories there's no logic there's no
mathematics there's no concepts of
beauty or truth that exist separate from
beauty and truthful things and and
therefore there can't even be a God I
mean the moment you say well there's
this God that lives outside of nothing
no that's that's not even possible by
that particular category you're making
another category error you know well
that there was no universe and then
there was well what where was he God
standing right create stand and then on
the other side the devil is do you know
Lawrence Krauss is of the world will say
all the laws of physics well where do
they come from
and where did the quantum vacuum come
from and from whose perspective are we
looking at the universe sort of
externally from to populate and create
the multiverse which is in a sort of a
long chain in the anthropic line of
argument but I want to talk a little bit
you know which relies on that but let me
just say authentically that you know
after my conversations with you I mean I
really kind of felt I understood in my
mind that at some point we all just have
to say I don't know nobody knows and and
this may be I don't know if you want to
go this far maybe one of these mysterion
mysteries where we'll never have an
answer to it right as you can always
some regress you know where'd the
multiverse come from you know right
whatever and that you know at some point
we just we just have a brain this size
that uses abstract concepts in a certain
way because of the structure of our
world that we evolved in and we we may
just not be able to conceive of
something that that far beyond our
epistemology yeah and we just have to
say you know what nobody knows I agree
completely actually next week is
Passover and I've pre-loaded a tweet you
know because I take off from work I
desist from work so I'm not like the
ancient Israelites enslaved and always
enslaved to my iPhone or my work my
telescopes so I pre-loaded for tweets
that I'm going to send out and it kind
of you act
off social media I do I do for you I
don't email and I actually command you
know such as I can my graduate students
because you know if you work six days
you know I work with a billionaire you
know I'm fortunate to be working with a
billionaire patron of my experiment Jim
Simon's who's rumored to be the world's
smartest billionaire and and you know he
also doesn't work seven days a week and
I asked him about that once and he sort
of came down on the same side that I do
which is which is if no matter how much
money you have if you you could be a
slave to many different you know we call
Kaiba's in Hebrew you know just
addictions that are they're not harmful
I mean they're not like you know doing
needle drugs or something like that it's
you know I'm teaching and rising my
students but to be on all the time and
part of the meaning of the word Sabbath
in Hebrew means a refreshing rest you
know it's almost like a pause that
refreshes that old soda jingle from the
70s but it is actually an active rest in
other words you're actually working to
rejuvenate your soul and I feel like
everybody on ben shapiro joke recently
like we're all we're all orthodox now
you know with with Kovach lockdown I
can't do that I can't drive we can't go
but getting a taste of it there are
actually green shoots I say spending
more time with my wife and kids and and
actually deep deep you know advising of
my graduate students that I just don't
have time for during the normal times
and and I just you know I feel like that
is that has been refreshing and and and
that to me is is interesting but you
know maybe that's maybe that's the
answer to your question about the
long-term consequences of the pandemic
maybe we'll all sort of build into our
our weeks a day of isolation yeah I mean
we didn't appreciate what we had one of
my friends you know tweeted out this
long list of things for herself or on
Facebook rather so that a year from now
it'll come up in her feed you know a
year ago memories from this time and
I'll say like you couldn't go to the
supermarket without standing on tape
markers that were six feet apart it's
inconceivable that we could but but
getting back to what you said these
these infinite regress is I find them
very delicious and my four questions you
know the famous for questions on
Passover you know why is this night
different from other nights and the
different children that asked these
questions it's meant to stimulate
inquiry my four questions and I'm
curious of where are your four questions
along this line mine are you know how
did the universe emerge how did some
income from nothing I think that might
be one of these chicken-or-egg questions
and I realize all of my questions are
basically that in other words how did
life originate from you know how did we
get from protons and neutrons to
croutons you know from from inanimate
things to things that life and then then
from croutons you know from Bach - from
bacteria to Bach and then you know and
then really into consciousness and is
there is there an ultimate end are we
alone and all these are chicken or the
and I think that that comfort that level
of intellectual facility I'm not saying
I exemplify it but I think you do and
that's - you're comfortable not saying I
know the answer like I don't know it's
okay to say I don't know and I think in
these times
everybody wants answers when is this
going to be over when are we going to
defeat this and it's not like a military
battle you knew when you'd win or lose
now it's like we have this indefinite
sentence against an literal invisible
foe and we don't know when it will end
or if it'll end but we know life will be
changed forever I think this will be you
know kind of I think ed Young said you
know this will be generation see instead
of Generation X Y or Z the kovat
generation that's good might change
things even more so we're coming to the
end I'm gonna be leaving soon I know you
have some commitments but I wanted to
finish up with a couple of quick quick
points one thing I've always wanted you
know you mentioned this a lot this is a
philosophic your brain for so much time
and so I want to take advantage of it
frequently in the book and elsewhere you
referenced Carl Sagan in this clip which
I didn't know was not his originally but
but that extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence you taught me
somebody else actually
yeah Martellus cruzi actually claiming
something but but it wasn't as artfully
put slightly longer and he wasn't as
well known so you get two effects one a
sharper shorter quip is more likely to
migrate up and there's that phenomena of
quotes migrate up to the most famous
person who ever said him as Yogi Berra
said I didn't say half the things I said
that's it's usually it's easy Yogi Berra
or Mark Twain and you know there's a
handful of others right and George
Bernard Shaw and exactly but you know
the way Carl put it I thought it was
more succinct you know and and of course
he said it you know on in cosmos you
know that half a billion people saw so
of course that that has a
as well but it was really first
articulated by David Hume in his
treatise on miracles about that a man
should portion is belief to the evidence
proportion will be evidence so the
principle proportionality you should you
know adjust as we would say and Bayesian
reasoning adjust your Creed's based on
investment of the priors and those are
always changing right so right you know
an ordinary claim requires ordinary
evidence you know if I say well I took
the one it is my example I took the 101
freeway south to the 118 of the 23 and I
went down and up at Chapman but by the
way at the junction of the 23 and the
101 I was abducted by aliens and we went
to the Pleiades and I met the platoons
who warned me to warn the Earthlings
about global warming but okay which part
of that story needs extraordinary
evidence okay right obviously so you
know and and and that's you know a basic
principle of all you know critical
thinking and reasoning like a scientist
is you know well what's the evidence and
right but the more extraordinary the
claim you know the the resurrection of
Jesus from the grave you know a hundred
billion people have lived and died
before the seven and a half billion
people alive today not one of them has
come back from the dead except for maybe
one maybe okay is the evidence that
would that's a hundred billion to one
miracle okay are the is the evidence a
hundred billion to one stronger for that
than other claims about what happened in
the Roman Empire about that no and
that's what I'm getting at really just
that shortly and a little home bridge
that I take at it you know there's
there's evidence but it's not like oh
I'm gonna go to my telescope and now I'm
gonna get some extraordinary evidence I
mean usually it's in quality or in
quantity in other words there's either
statistical you know or or systematic
sort of uncertainty and associated with
with Dana and you know so if a hundred
million a million people said the same
thing happen would that make you believe
in one specific person yeah so you have
to adjust your priors to do that but I
think you know maybe my broader point is
that we do have sort of this culture
that now with the decline of of religion
and the rise of the nuns as your former
guests Aukerman Phil's Aukerman I think
yeah that he talks about a documented
sir college you know that who are we as
substituting science and and even
scientists as sort of idols I make the
case in my book losing the Nobel Prizes
the Nobel Prize to a scientist you
almost can't read a book in fact your
book has you know half a dozen mentions
of just the words Nobel Prize and that's
fine but we kind of use it as this
imprimatur and I always point you know
there's four hundred you know got guys
in Sweden that decide this every year
and not not taking anything away from
from the winners because they don't
choose to win it that's actually the
only only stipulation you can't nominate
yourself I always point out that reduced
the challenge by one person out of seven
billion when I had to nominate people
but the point is you know we kind of
want people we need as you quote also in
this book you know it's really so so
uncanny how how you you know you came
into my dreams and you and you extracted
all these things out of my mind but but
one of the things that I always talk
about is the scene from a few good men
where Jack Nicholson basically comes
down you know you can't handle the truth
you know which my father you see they
should have said illiterate it should
have been illiterate it's just that you
can't take the truth but the point is
like you need me on that wall you want
me on that wall because you know who's
gonna do it you and I think people in
society the more educated but not
scientifically educated this is more
true prep they want you know these kind
of fifth degree blackbelt intellects
like like the Nobel laureates like the
Carl Sagan's etc and and nowadays we're
seeing with like doctor foul Chi like
every anything he said like the cut off
drunk during his speech you know and
then those immediately breaking news
we're gonna factories talking about like
economics he doesn't know anything about
that and we have this halo effect and I
wonder you know that extends I mean Carl
Sagan was a masterful scientific
communicator and he did great science as
well and and it's sort of unique our
friend Neil deGrasse Tyson he often says
you know when somebody asked me to
comment on some scientific discovery I
don't comment on it I referred to a real
scientist working in that field he's of
course an astrophysicist trained you
know it to you know a PhD but I think
the you know the point is we tend to
really want to you know lionize and and
and and regard scientist and I wonder do
you feel like that is a consequence just
from
observations of the decline of religion
that science and scientists in
particular have taken on this sort of
outsized role which you know i-i-i
evilly will benefit from right yeah yeah
interesting
maybe I mean I think there's several
things that could come of the rise of
the nuns that really started in the say
the 60s one explanation we have for the
New Age movement to this sort of New Age
spiritual movement and crystals and spur
ology and all that psychic stuff what
was the decline of mainstream religion
it was already starting then not not
amongst the general population but just
the you know decline of power and
influence of religion which is why in
the 80s you know the moral majority rose
up it's like that was a push back
against what was already happening they
want to get back in the business of
having power and control that churches
once had and the Middle Ages an early
modern period but we're losing so and I
think one explanation for why people
like creationists are so obsessed with
you know getting into science because we
live in the age of science if you want
to make an argument for a creator you
got to use the language of scientists
you know you got to talk about the fine
tunas and the Big Bang and all that
stuff or else you're not in the
conversation anymore so I think
scientists really have been elevated
just general as a population but like
when I remember when Stephen Hawking
used to come to Caltech every year and
he would give a public talk and you know
this is in in you know Beckman
auditorium 11-under seats you know and
it was standing room only and they were
lined up out all afternoon they get in
there and you know he gets a standing
ovation for showing up yeah and it's not
and you know Sagan commanded audiences
like but talking even more cuz I think
the disease it was a sense of like this
brain there's just a pure brain yeah you
know there's no bodies it's a pure brain
of just pure thought yeah and you know
sorry I get that you know it's a it's a
kind of you know communication yeah
there is a there's a Hubble fellowship
at the that NASA puts out the most
prestigious post doctoral fellowship
there's an Einstein fellowship and
there's a Sagan fellowship you know
there is so this looks for you know
astrobiology and and and stellar
astrophysics and all the good things
that he worked in you know I wrote a
paper on the Sagan effect in which I
actually looked at if there was such a
thing as the second effect the second
effect is if you start popularizing
science your real science productivity
will go down nope not in the case of
Sagan nor with Gould they were both I
think they both pushed over 500
peer-reviewed published journal articles
although to be fair a lot of Sagan's
were in you know for NASA publications
that is the same NASA Purdue so that was
him and 500 other sciences or whatever
that's well he was you know productively
active in there so you can do both and
but I think just to say that because
cosmic we're recording is cosmos is
airing season three now yeah the second
one of the reboot with Neil and you know
there's a you know a andrian is
definitely written kind of a
spirituality into the whole cosmic story
which is all science but underlying it
and there's rather poetic writing you
know most of what Neil says is you know
and dreams words it's right and you know
there's in a way I think science is our
mythic story about who we are where we
came from where we're going what it all
means you know and everybody knows that
which is why again theologians
creationists everybody you know they
can't they kind of come to you to say
what are my best arguments for God's
existence I just use an Psalms arguments
anymore I need the Big Bang updated I
need I need the inflationary cosmology
how can I build this into my theology
and it's funny because I told you on the
podcast we recorded for a science salon
you know on the day that bicep2 of the
experiment that I helped co-create
announced that we had discovered
evidence you know direct evidence for
inflation you know both the Discovery
Institute and Lawrence Krauss you know
took
completely diametrically opposed even I
both agreed we were going to win Nobel
prizes but but where they disagreed is
you know once that this is clear
evidence for the fine-tuning and the
existence of God the other one said this
is the exact the evidence max tegmark
and others you know that we don't need
Krauss always calls a supernatural you
know the shenanigans or whatever but
getting to religion and I want to
conclude first let me conclude actually
I'm gonna take this around maybe will
edit it maybe we won't it's kind of fun
just to go all around with you and kind
of just riff and you talked about going
on a going on a version of a Hitchens
century mile you know ride but it was
regarding drinking in the book that
spoiler for the readers but you should
get the book just for the just for the
the stories hitch stories he was quite a
character and um I had a chance you know
to hear but I you know it's just take
advantage of everybody take advantage of
chances you have to hear the great minds
so let me go from are we just discuss
God and religion I want to talk about
the origin of the name of this podcast
is into the impossible and that comes
from what are known as Arthur she
Clarke's three laws and so he says
Clarke's first law is that when
distinguished but elderly scientist
states that something is possible he is
almost certainly right nowadays we'd say
he or she when he or she stay states
that something is impossible he is very
probably wrong that's Clarke's number
one law number two is where we get our
name for the podcast the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and it's the name of
our of our podcast and then there is
Clarke's third law which connects to
schirmer's last law and that is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
and I want to just give you the
opportunity can you explain what is
schirmer's last slide now you didn't
really you kind of named it after
yourself but it's you did so you did so
with with great humility I don't think
yeah your van glorious enough but it
actually has some resonance to this so
can you explain what schirmer's lost
yeah of course aware of Clark's three
laws going all the way back to being in
college because he was such an icon for
so many of us getting started in the
sciences and but his third law I always
liked because it's a great example of
when I say there's no such thing as the
supernatural or the paranormal
it's just what appears to be that
because we don't have an explanation for
it yet such that you know
current example I use of this is that
paraplegic guy that alright no he's a
quadriplegic
that has a chip in his motor cortex and
he can control the cursor on his
computer and he can do emails and play
video games and whatnot just by thinking
now if you don't know about the chip in
the brain it looks like he has
telekinesis he's moving things with his
thoughts right so you know I can imagine
a time sort of like a Michiyo Kaku the
future of the brain where you know we
all have these chips and computers and
we're wirelessly connected to the
Internet you walk into your house and
you just think Mozart Mozart comes on
much like today we go LX at play Mozart
yeah just set off a thousand Alexa's
around the world and so something like
that so then I got to thinking about
that in the context of SETI and the
possibility of extraterrestrial
intelligence now my connection there
professionally is you know debunking the
UF ologists and hailing abductees and
all that stuff debunking explaining but
there's you know real science you know
are they out there and had they come
here to separate questions are they out
there well as you know everybody knows
they scientists know they're not going
to be just like us you know like bipedal
primates you know speaking English with
a weird accent with gnarly stuff on the
forehead like on Star Trek now these are
the limitations of Hollywood wardrobes
but but neither are they going to be
culturally or scientifically anywhere
close to us you know so these stories
you hear about you know the alien craft
landed in Roswell and we back engineered
silicon chips you know which were like
five years away otherwise you know so
the aliens were only five years ahead of
us you know this is impossible you know
just because on an evolutionary
timescale the chances of a alien species
evolving lockstep with us you know in
some other part of the galaxy perfectly
within a few years is you know zilch
they're going to either be way behind us
which case we'll never encounter them
because you know they're not going to
have radio technology or spaceships and
unless we go there or they're gonna be
ahead of us how far ahead of us you know
hundred thousand years a million years a
billion years you know look what we've
accomplished Moore's law and so on just
in the last century extrapolate that out
they will be godlike to us right this
idea is not original to many science
fiction writers have played with this
for
long time but I just codified it linking
it to Clarke's third law by calling it
schirmer's last law because I'm never
gonna name it love myself it's just a
tongue-in-cheek point but the point is
that you know the future of you know
what we will be and you can also apply
this to far future humans yeah you know
like what will you know what will the
internet be like in a century from now
well hell no one predicted the Internet
just like in 1956 I mean you know -
pretty - pretty much everybody by
surprise well you know how it evolved so
we just don't know and when we don't
know it just seems godlike yeah and that
and that that's the point of that
interesting I mean so I want to conclude
by talking about well one less thing
about books I've done it a commonality
just want to get your opinion so there's
a great deal of popularity on social
psychology on books such as yours even
Pinker's count'em ins etc and there's
also a tremendous influence and I think
they're outsized and in terms of their
proportion of scientists that are
actually doing the work between the
number of books written by psychologist
or social scientists and also
astronomers and I wonder if that's and I
want to get your take on this maybe it's
total nonsense I don't be afraid to say
so but I think you know psychology and
astronomy are both the only two Sciences
one soft one hard I suppose that can be
done with the tools and and experimental
equipment that one is born with namely
psychology and astronomy done with your
eyeballs which I always point out to
refracting telescopes and really nothing
more and yeah I just wonder what you
know there's a surge in popularity of
books such as yours and your friend
Steven Pinker I should read his blurb
which because it's quite quite
voluminous and it's praise and Michael
Shermer is our foremost Explorer of
alternative crackpot and dangerous ideas
and at the same time one of our most
powerful voices for science sanity and
humane values in this engrossing
collection Shermer shows why these
missions are consistent it's the search
light of reason that best exposes errors
and evil and I think you guys have very
you know common common themes and some
of your other books but I think what
distinguishes you is that you're kind of
a little bit broader that you you really
go into territory the physical sciences
and and explore things in a little bit
more detail although I should point out
both of you guys are really outstanding
teachers and he has a free course or a
course that's his Harvard University
course on rationality which I've been
watching along with my kids and my
nieces and nephews and that's that's
called rationality and I urge people to
go out and listen to it because he's got
some of the greatest minds and he is one
of the greatest muse and he's also one
of these Devils right that that isn't
afraid to to take a side that that's
controversial that could get him into
trouble but he goes were reason sort of
impels him to go he's fearless steve is
fearless and he's a great writer you
know great writing still makes a
difference and I love seeing that books
like Steve's and Richard Dawkins yeah
for example Steve gold was a great
writer and you know it's it's
interesting you mentioned about you know
astronomy books or whatever you know
when I was in conse in high school in
college it seemed like the most popular
science books were where astronomy books
yeah and I don't recall there being you
know any psych books maybe be of Skinner
perhaps he's beyond freedom and dignity
and and Walden's
yeah Walden's pond oh yeah well they're
on too right
yeah anyway but but I think we're seeing
the rise now more of this because people
because becoming more recognizable that
the methods of science can be applied to
these social questions political
question question of no race and
economics and policy and and
consciousness I mean you know the study
of consciousness that really didn't even
begin to the late 90s right you know
when Francis Crick said it's okay to
study the mind it's like oh Francis
Crick well he won the Nobel Prize you
know for his work in genetics oh he said
it's just okay so it must be okay you
know
and then vibrator and then Dan Dennett
writes books on this and pretty soon you
know the study of consciousness is no
longer a whoohoo thing it's now a
scientific so I think that's happening
everywhere I'm trying to push it into we
know moral questions you know that
scientists science if they can't
determine human values it could
certainly inform
and that that has to be okay and that
you know as I after in giving the devil
his due mr. Hume tear down this wall
you know this wall separating is a not
this so-called naturalistic fallacy
which I think is something of a policy
though technically my philosopher
friends and I'm not a philosopher
telling me I did I still haven't quite
done it but my point is that you know
just saying you know just punting the
ball down the field and say well we
scientists we have nothing to say about
morals and values and purpose in life
that's for the theologians [ __ ] come
on it's okay for scientists to at least
have an opinion yeah make a rational
argument and then put forth some
empirical ideas data about it we should
be excluding to do so right yeah very
good so I wanna I put out on Twitter and
Facebook an invitation to fans of the
podcast to submit some questions we
don't have too much time but I did get a
couple that I wanted to highlight so one
was by an anonymous listener who wanted
to know what is your perspective of kind
of the future of skepticism looking at
videos this person feels you know that
you tend to see a lot of white-haired
you know old white men the dreaded old
white men in the audience and wondering
where do you see the kind of ability of
skepticism to sort of transcend
demographic bounds
yeah that person is probably referring
to the so-called skeptical movement
which you know sort of officially began
in the 70s with cyclop the committee for
the scientific investigation of claims
of the paranormal never the best
different best title now shortened to
CFI Center for inquiry you know James
Randi Paul Kurtz Ray Hyman Martin
Gardner you know all you know basically
responding to the New Age movement and
people like Harry Geller Benny galleons
and psychics in theology and all that
stuff they were worried about you know
what this was have an effect on
education and policy and and whatnot and
so that was definitely for decades you
know sort of an old white guys movement
as was so many of these kind of
movements at the time now things are
thankfully changing you see a lot more
women at these events and a lot more
people of color although it's still you
know pretty heavily slanted but but I
prefer to not really think of it myself
as part of the skeptics movement
I'd rather broaden it it's sort of
scientific humanism or enlightenment
humanism and I know you secondly
humanism anymore for this reason because
it really began in the 1930s and was
very much a far left liberal political
movement you know for good causes you
know for you know reproductive rights
for women and civil rights for
minorities and all this all this good
stuff but then by the 80s and 90s it
became like well if you don't take these
12 boxes of our political beliefs you're
not a humanist it's like I only took
like half those boxes you know I'm
socially liberal but I'm kind of
fiscally conservative and I it depends
I'm sort of you know you know an issues
guy tell me the issue no no no this is
the whole set if you don't believe all
of them you're out and it's like okay
that's not for me that's thing thinking
kind of what happened to the skeptics
movement and also the atheist movement
after Richards book mm mm-hmm it kind of
was a split between the militant
atheists and and sort of moderate
atheists or agnostics and skeptics or
whatever and it's like if you're not
militant like like hit or Richard
Dawkins and you're not a true atheist
like right guys there's not that many of
us okay so you know started kicking
people out of the club is not the best
strategy right yeah and I think this
happens with all social movements you
know that the sort of purification of
you know who's not towing the line
perfectly I think it's very dangerous
I'd rather go for what I'm calling
scientific humanism or enlightenment
human just humanism in the broadest
sense everybody should be practice
skepticism of course concerns of what I
think like a scientist everybody should
think like a scientist we all want to
know what's reliable valid knowledge
that we should embrace and what's not
that we should withhold judgment or
reject that that question applies to
everything yeah I even tell my my you
know religious friends and Christians
and Muslims and and Jews that you know
if you are you know maybe not a
scientist you should not fear science
you should not oppose science because
actually science could lead you to a
deepening of your understanding just as
steel sure
and steal your arguments your faith may
be strengthened by looking into sign so
certainly it's there's no need for you
know even that the kind of date on of
non-overlapping magisteria but but even
in the case of actively learning about
science not relegating that's you know
it's like George Bush was one George
Bush Senior was once asked you know like
if you took all the deficit dollars and
you stack them up how big would they how
long would they travel or something like
that and he was like oh don't bother me
but I'm not a math guy and I won't ever
say like don't bother me I'm not I'm not
a words guy you know I don't speak
English you know I don't understand
English or syntax of proper proper
grammar um but there's sort of this
discomfort or sometimes a badge of honor
I don't understand science you guys for
those monkey eggheads
yeah and so I think you know seeking out
that diversity of viewpoint is so
important and it's one of the things you
do extremely well I want to ask a couple
more questions so one of the listeners
asked me your opinions on the anti
vaccination crowd are they Devils that
should be you know listened to in the
sense that you know if you don't believe
the vaccinations are if you actually
believe that vaccinations are deadly is
that or cause autism for example should
you be excluded from the marketplace of
ideas
well no not excluded in any legal sense
no censorship for anybody but it you
know and the voice of people that were
skeptical of vaccines was actually heard
in a century ago now there was a great
debate in 1890s and early 1900s about
the values of value of vaccinations and
legitimate debates you know in the 19th
century about you know how best to do
this does it really work is it really
worth the risk and so on but you know as
you know in science at some point we you
know we kind of reach a consensus akan
salience of inductions a convergence of
evidence from multiple lines of inquiry
that go you know what this is really the
best explanation let's theory the best
policy or whatever we should go with
that
okay there's always going to be
dissenters what do you what do you do
with them well you don't have to do
anything you just ignore them right the
problem is when they when we start
influencing the body politic and you get
a lot of people that don't back today
then you reach this herd you know you
preach the herd immunity and all that
that people are probably familiar with
now still of course I mean like this guy
who did the autism's linked to
vaccinations his name is escaping me now
but sorry you know no I don't think you
should be you know censored or jailed or
anything like that but you know I think
it requires a more stronger voice that
we stand up and say you know we really
we really need to follow the science
ouchy kind of voice you know someone
that people really trust which so I
think public intellectuals such as
yourself and Neil deGrasse Tyson and
others you know it's important that they
speak up and speak speak who's the power
is they used to say all right because
that you know we live in the age of
science and you know you know the fringe
voices are okay that's good let's see
what they have and say but but let's put
forth their best argument and then
respond and then be done with it okay do
you feel like that would lead to I mean
you've written extensively in the moral
arc and elsewhere about you know the
civilizations that are last to adopt you
know women's rights gay lesbian
transgender right that those you know
those are declining there's very few of
those that exist and do you think that
kind of freedom of speech supersedes all
of them in other words that that if you
have that then it would translate into
more wider acceptance in different parts
of the world that don't already have
those those freedoms that we now take
for granted in the West at least yeah
free speech is I think the foundation of
all other rights the right to think and
speak what you want because that's the
only way to find out if if we're right
or wrong about a particular something
else having to do with civil rights and
civil liberties so and and we know this
because the first thing that autocrats
do is they shut down two centers they
scream they want to control the press
you know and it's a by their actions you
can tell which which is the most
important of all the rights it's the
right to speak that's the first one we
want to squelch yes and the last
question from a friend as is a Bernie
Taylor author of a book called before
Orion a scholar a naturalist about
ancient cave paintings and what he wants
to know is is there something deep and
the so-called gods of old from
really prehistoric times 36 thousand
years ago he says that are projected
forward in some sense psychologically is
there something in the believing brain
as you would say that compelled the the
worshipers you know my ancient tradition
Judaism and the judeo-christian
traditions is there some embedding of
this really Paleolithic you know in our
Paleolithic Minds that carried forward
to the to the modern or less ancient to
the Bronze Age certainly something had
to come along with it because their us
yeah right the people that made these
cave paintings there are Homo sapiens
their brains are pretty much just like
ours with different cultures so what
gets carried forward is probably some
foundational structure to cognition but
then creates these stories and myths or
whatever you know I have a chapter in
giving the devil is Duan Graham Hancock
the romance the the romance of the past
and your your correspondent there I
think is hinting at that you know
there's something about the wisdom of
the ancient ones you know and and I
think there's something to that in as
much as you know certain traditions like
your own Jewish tradition you know they
you know they experimented with many
different things long ago and so what we
find some of which may have value now
you have to test each claim to see which
has value but some of them may I'll give
you an example I just had Brian Greene
in my podcast with his new book but you
know he's an atheist who doesn't believe
in God whatever it is but you know when
his father died he said he really cling
to the you know sort of Jewish tradition
of that Shiva yeah yeah
and that you know the rabbi and you know
the traditions they went through and all
that that it made him feel like well
this is goes back thousands of years so
it feels deeper to me like this is a
meet a more meaningful transition for my
father and and for the rest of us that
are still alive that we have that
tradition and I joke you mean like the
Seinfeld Festivus for the rest of us
with the metal pole that was your father
that was invented you know last Tuesday
that's not going to do it it doesn't
have a sense of gravity
so I I do recognize that and and in the
other chapter in the in the book about
Jordan Peterson I acknowledge the value
of myths and stories that have their own
kind of truth now I don't go as far as
he does about defining truth that well
but the idea that you know novels and
ancient religious writings could have
even if they're whether they're true or
not is irrelevant you know even whether
it's you know the noachian flood in the
ark or jesus resurrected yeah none of it
could it's possible none of it happened
that their mythic stories that carry
some moral homily or some message about
you know what you burying your own cross
you know forgiving people starting over
you know redemption these are these are
kind of moral truths in a way that I
think have value yeah that's stand the
test of time right that's interesting I
didn't know that about Brian I mean I
listen to the - oh and then hoping to
get him on the podcast you should do
that because he's an interesting guy so
I want to close with an opportunity I
called the the plug zone if there are
things that you want to plug besides
this book so this is coming out April
6th Tuesday as all books Duke that's
schirmer's first law which is which is
that books always come out on Tuesdays
it's actually interestingly this one
comes out on Thursday a pollenate for
some weird reason oh maybe because it's
original public the publisher is
Cambridge University Press
yeah and I went through their London
office so they're in England so for some
reason in England the Tuesday rule
doesn't apply it's an American rolling
okay so it's not a universal roll okay
so like you know it's just skeptic tom
is the webpage of my magazine my gamer
comm is my personal webpage and you know
Amazon book stores are all closed so you
know yeah
great time to have a non-fiction book
but of course Amazon is still delivering
I read this morning they just hired
80,000 people or something like that
yeah that's great and of course the
local bookstores you know we had hope to
have you here I should say for an event
and we will have you here hopefully in
the fall at UCSD by then you'll have
written three more books so that'll be
nice well I'll be wearing facemasks ed
gloves and fist bumping or you know yeah
well I mean the virus isn't going to go
away
because we all go back to work yes
exactly right yeah it'll still be there
hopefully we'll have a great
breakthrough with my colleagues and
their friends around the world working
so hard on this it's really an
unprecedented time so I want to also
refer people to the fact that you are
you you have courses on the great
courses which you can also get through
audible now they're a sponsor of the
science salon podcast which I tuned into
all the time the book launch as we said
and this should air before the book
actually launches and you're chatting
lectures and everything is there
anything else that you want to mention
or that I forgot to or maybe say
everything yeah I guess that that's
pretty much it okay it's so much fun
talking to you Santa Barbara let go for
a ride and though I've been riding it
I've been riding in isolation there's no
more group rides number of rides
anywhere what do you call it peloton so
it's telenovela faced those guys they
sweat and spit and you know no you don't
want to be anywhere near a building
we'll get you here for for a talk in San
Diego as soon as we can and it's
everyone out there thank you so much
[Music]
- sure about the future is it will be
absolutely
[Music]